c'est reparti comme en quarante cinq
ces affiches de la loi de réquisition
remise à l'ordre du jour par le maire de
paris ne sont pas au goût de tous
dans la ligne de mire de jacques chirac
les logements aux bureaux vacants des
grands groupes financiers
quelle surface exacte occupe-t-il à
paris peu de chiffres circulent
officiellement sur la question
d'après l'insee 3 millions 500 mille
mètres carrés de bureaux sont
actuellement vides en de france pour la
moitié à paris quant aux logements
vacants
il faudrait au nombre de 18 dans les
mains d'un petit nombre
d'institutionnels à 5 15 % de l'ensemble
des propriétaires privés qui dénoncent
une mesure à court terme
la classe politique
pas de panique arrêter de raisonner
comme cela en perdant votre sang froid
et à chaud sur l'événement une mesure de
réquisition qui est d'abord détestable
sur le plan de la confiance en général
est ensuite une mesure onéreuse
puisqu'il va falloir que l'état en paie
le prix
moi je crois qu'il est préférable que
l'argent disponible soit affecté plus
tôt à recyclage sur le marché de locaux
vacants appartenant à des propriétaires
qui ont envie de les remettre sur le
marché vacant et y cas lisez plutôt que
pénaliser petits propriétaires et
gouvernement se rejoignent depuis des
années sur la même façon de relancer le
marché
nous évoquons la loi de réquisition mais
ne mettant pas en priorité quand
maintiendra ses parts en créant 92 à
l'initiative de l'abbé pierre
ce comité au logement des personnes
défavorisées remettra fin janvier son
rapport au président de la république et
au premier ministre